the Dolphins have been dominating games
this year with speed and we have the
stat to prove it every week the NFL
tracks who has the fastest ball carrier
and every single week the fastest ball
carrier has been a dolphin check it out
their top speed was just under Olympic
runner Usain Bolt's average speed of
23.35 miles per hour but it's no
coincidence that the guys are all so
fast Tyrique moster and a chain were all
major track stars in college Tyreke was
the track and field News high school
athlete of the year in 2012. he even ran
6.70 seconds in a 60 meter USA Track and
Field Master indoor championship event
this year moster won the Big Ten title
in the 60 meter and 200 meter indoor
track championship at Purdue and a chain
was an NCAA All-American in the 4 by 100
in 2021. it's not uncommon for NFL
athletes to also run track and field but
the Dolphins front office clearly has an
eye for Speedy dual sport athletes on
offense